I personally don't look at cheating and
in my work I don't look at cheating and
think that's the end
hi my name is Omar Torrez I'm a licensed
clinical social worker here in New York
and today we are going to answer the
most googled questions about
relationships what does a healthy
relationship look like in my experience
some of the healthier aspects of a
relationship that I noticed involve
mutual respect to people that have
similar interests but also separate
lives so they have their own friends
they have their own hobbies to have
their own interests and they can share
it with their partner here and there but
it's not contingent upon their partner
being there what is an open relationship
an open relationship is essentially any
non monogamous relationship if you're
considering an open relationship first
and foremost I would try and do a little
bit of research so there's a really
great book called the ethical [ __ ] and
honestly you know this might sound kind
of boring or cliche but open
communication you have to talk about
what the expectations are what the
boundaries are essentially you just want
to keep those lines of communication
open and it's gonna be an ongoing
conversation jealousy and open
relationships is common totally healthy
when those jealous feelings come up the
way you talk about it with your partner
is essential right so hey I'm having
these feelings they're really
uncomfortable I could really use your
support can we chat about this thing
that happened that's like kicking up
some stuff in me as opposed to you know
what some people do when they feel
really jealous is that they think I'm
not allowed to have this feeling so they
keep it inside and that tends to fester
sometimes resentment can grow from that
some folks are able to have sex with
another individual and not have it
impact the romantic relationship and
others have a really difficult time
doing there and it's something that
could work for some couples and may not
for others that's why the ongoing
conversations are so important and it's
also really important for you to know
for yourself what sex means to you and
to know what sex means for your partner
what is a poly relationship poly
relationships refer to more than just
two individuals in
romantic relationship so you may often
hear the term throttle what I've found
in poly relationships that are
successful is that there tends to be a
structure in place already there might
be one partner that sort of fulfills you
sexually and another partner that
fulfills you intellectually and so on
and so forth so everyone sort of like
has a role how to build trust in a
relationship for some people building
trust means spending time together
having experiences together I also find
that any kind of relationship that goes
through like a problem or like an issue
where they have to work together as a
team that can be a really bonding
experience so for individuals that have
a history of being cheated on you might
feel a little resistant or hesitant to
jump into a relationship and just trust
them fully so first and foremost go to
therapy right and and talk about the
experience of betrayal and make sure
that you feel fully healed and sort of
on the other end of all that pain and
betrayal because that's a lot that's a
lot to go through so that way you can
enter into the new relationship not
necessarily giving them all of your
trust right away but allowing them to
work for that trust I will say that I
have seen relationships recover
beautifully from cheating and from
affairs so I I personally don't look at
cheating and in my work I don't look at
cheating and think that's the end right
that that's that the affair is seen as a
symptom of a larger issue that needs to
be addressed how to make a long-distance
relationship work when it comes to
long-distance relationships you have to
be mindful of how you're investing in
that relationship right so how often are
you speaking are you emailing are you
texting are you facetiming another
really good strategy that I find for
long-distance relationships is to plan
anywhere between three to six months out
in advance what the travel plans will be
putting that on a calendar will give the
two of you something to look forward to
how do you know when your relationship
is over
if you really don't feel strongly one
way or the other about the relationship
or about your partner that is definitely
a sign that something's off and it may
mean that you need to renegotiate the
terms of the relationship or that the
relationship maybe isn't right for you
anymore or at that time what I've also
noticed is that folks that feel like the
relationship is ending we'll often think
about future plans but without their
partner how to get over a relationship
first and foremost it's recognizing that
this sort of thing takes time allow
yourself to be set there's nothing wrong
with being sad and upset after a
relationship remember things like oh
yeah they used to like never show up for
me or oh yeah they lied all the time so
to sort of go over the things that
weren't so great about the relationship
and then finally to think about things
that have nothing to do with the
relationship take up a hobby spend time
with friends this isn't something that
happens overnight this isn't something
that you know it doesn't necessarily
take a couple of weeks or maybe even a
couple of months it's a case by case
should I get back together with my ex
some of the things that you want to be
mindful of is time apart you know was
there enough time between the breakup
and now that allowed for the two of you
to learn and grow and heal from the past
pain or is it going to feel like a
continuation of the same and if it is a
continuation of the same then you're
probably going to run into the same
issues obviously so I hope you all found
that helpful and I hope some of the
answers I gave you provided a little bit
of insight or a little bit of hope or
inspiration and barring anything extreme
I am a firm believer that there isn't
anything that a relationship can't
recover from if everyone involved agrees
to work together and to do the work
[Music]